Prince Harry he's back in the UK this
morning to begin his final series of
engagements as a senior royal now this
is his first public appearance since he
and his wife Megan Markel finalized her
split from the royal family Charlie
d'Agata reports on buckin palace on the
parts of the arrangement that Harry and
Megan are not happy with he's made it
clear that we are all just to call him
Harry so ladies and gentlemen please
give a big warm Scottish welcome to
Harry ready to shed the royal label just
Harry was back on the job this morning
his appearance in Edinburgh is his first
engagement since he and Megan plunged
into a messy divorce with the royal
family Thank You Aisha good morning
everyone
in their first official statement since
the Queen's decision to rip the use of
the royal brand away from them last week
they questioned the Crown's
jurisdiction on their website while
there is not any jurisdiction by the
monarchy over the use of the word royal
overseas the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
do not intend to use any iteration of
the word royal in any territory they had
planned on using Sussex royal as the
brand for their charitable foundations
and business ventures the royal fuss has
only widened the rift within the family
itself says Sunday Times royal
correspondent Roy Anika by putting out
that statement again it was almost a
little bit petulant saying you know we
were doing this we don't have to do this
but we're doing this for now they're
serving their notice by the end of next
month appearances like this will come to
an end and while Harry and Megan may be
shedding their royal obligations gone
too will be all the perks and privileges
that come with it
now as for Megan and baby Archie it's
believed they are still back in Canada
her first official public appearance
here will be on March 5th
Anthony Charlie d'Agata at Buckingham
Palace thank you Charlie
something tells me that's gonna work out
okay we have to get used to I have to
get used to snot saying Prince Harry
just saying here's Harry I'm okay with
that